vamos a dibujar o graficar algunas
desigualdades así que digamos que tengo
la desigualdad de menor o igual que 4 x
3 y lo que queremos es pintar esto en el
plano x y queremos mostrar todos los
puntos x que satisfacen la condición de
aquí arriba así que una forma buena de
empezar esto es qué pasa cuando no es
una desigualdad si no es una igualdad es
decir o decir bueno déjame ponerlo de
esta forma esto es lo mismo que poner
menor que 4 x 3 o ye igual a 4 x 3
esto es lo que menor o igual significa
que puede ser menor o que también puede
ser igual y la razón de por qué el hice
primero este ejemplo es porque quiero
que veamos qué pasa con esta gráfica que
subraya entonces pongo mis 6 déjeme
pintarlo un poquito mejor
y no me fallo ok ahí está mi eje
vertical el eje i
y vamos a pintar el eje x justo aquí muy
bien ok y ahora sabemos que esto es una
gráfica de una línea donde se intersecta
con el eje y en el 3 ok por aquí pasa y
tenemos la pendiente que es 4 positivo
verdad si es 4 positivo quiere decir que
por cada uno que nos movamos en la
dirección de x nos movemos 4 en la
dirección de iu entonces aquí va a estar
otro punto porque ya con esto es
suficiente para dibujar una línea verdad
porque ahora sí nos vamos uno a la
izquierda entonces bajamos cuatro en la
dirección vertical así que esto va a ser
mi mejor intento de dibujar una línea
espero que realmente salga la parte más
difícil de todo lo que se vería algo
como esto
esto es una línea debería ser derechita
pero creo que tienen la idea y esta es
la gráfica de 4 x 3
así que pensemos en lo que significa que
sea menor street así que todos estos
puntos satisfacen la desigualdad pero
tenemos más este justo de aquí por
ejemplo qué pasa cuando bueno vamos a
ayudar en algunos casos particulares
vamos a pensar qué es lo que significa
esto así que tomamos algún valor x
digamos que pasa si x es igual a 0 que
nos dice entonces si x es igual a cero
nos dice que ya es menor que 4 x 0 que 0
más 3 que es 3 son digamos ahora cuando
x es igual a menos 1 entonces tenemos
que menor que 4 x menos uno que es menos
4 + 3 tenemos que es menor que menos 1
si x es igual a 1 digamos que sería
menor que 4 por 1 que es 4 3 es 7 así
que tendríamos que ya es menor que 7 así
que vamos a tratar de graficar esto
cuando
cuando x es igual a graficar este
primero cuando x es igual a 0 y es menor
que 3 ok entonces cuando x es igual a 0
tenemos todos estos puntos de aquí toda
esta línea que estoy sombreando de verde
satisfacen esto de aquí si fuera mirar
ahora en x igual a menos 1 y es menor
que menos 1 ok y es menor que menos 1
así que ya tienen que ser todos estos
puntos de abajo toda esta línea cuando x
es igual a 1 y es menor que 7 ok
entonces si es menor que 7 son todos
estos puntos que estoy sombreando y en
general si tomamos cualquier punto
digamos cualquier punto x digamos que
tomamos un punto x por aquí si evaluamos
4 x 3 vamos a tener este punto sobre la
línea que eso es 4 x x + 3
ok y ahora las 10 que satisfacen la
desigualdad pueden serlo pueden ser los
puntos en la línea o todos los que están
debajo de ella así que si hacemos esto
para todos los posibles x
vemos en la recta no no vamos a tener
solo los que están en la línea que que
ya hemos dibujado vamos a tener todos
los puntos debajo de esta línea así que
ya hemos graficado esta desigualdad
esencialmente es esta línea con toda el
área debajo de ella que estamos
sembrando ahora si esto fuera un menor
estricto y no un menor o igual un signo
de menor o igual entonces no hubiéramos
incluido la línea y la convención que
vamos a tomar para hacer eso es puntear
la línea así que si si esa fuera la
situación que estuviéramos tratando con
un signo de menor estricto a menor
estricto que 4 x 3
en esta situación no aplicaríamos poner
la línea en el conjunto solución así que
sólo nos quedaría el área debajo de ella
vamos a hacer otro ahora digamos que
tenemos la desigualdad
mayor que menos x entre 2 menos 6 así
que una forma buena de empezar y como a
mí me gusta hacerlo al menos es graficar
la ecuación de aquí la línea que tenemos
vamos a graficar de igual a menos un
medio de x menos 6
así que si fuéramos a graficar lo
digamos este es mi eje vertical
y este es el eje horizontal el eje x
nos dice que la intersección con el eje
10 menos 6
ok aquí está el -6 y mi pendiente es
menos un medio aquí debería haber una
equis verdad es menos un medio de equis
ok entonces tengo una pendiente de menos
un medio que quiere decir que cuando voy
uno a la derecha perdón dos a la derecha
bajo uno en g
ok entonces dos a la derecha y bajo uno
si voy dos a la izquierda tengo menos
dos en equis y subo uno verdad así que
mi línea se va a ver algo así más o
menos se ve algo así es mi mejor intento
para dibujar una línea así que esta es
la línea de igualdad menos un medio de x
menos 6 ahora nuestra desigualdad no es
mayor o igual simplemente son todos
aquellos números mayores que menos un
medio de x entre 2 perdón menos un medio
de x menos seis así que usando la misma
lógica que antes para cualquier x que
nos tomemos digamos aquí está un x
particular si evaluamos en menos x entre
2 menos 6 tenemos este punto de aquí
este punto en la línea pero las 'íes'
que satisfacen esta desigualdad son
todas las 10 mayores que eso así que no
vamos a incluir este punto de hecho
vamos a poner un círculo abierto porque
no podemos incluir ese punto
y de ahí vamos a tomarnos todas las 10
más grandes que eso
ok eso sería cierto para cualquier equis
por ejemplo tomamos estas evaluamos
menos un medio de x menos seis obtenemos
este otro punto ponemos un circulito
abierto y tomamos todas las 10 que están
arriba de él así que todas las 10 que
satisfacen esta ecuación o esta
desigualdad son aquellos puntos cuyas
coordenadas estén por arriba de esta
línea y no estamos incluyendo la línea
así que como la convención que dijimos
vamos a puntear la línea ok déjenme
convertirlo en una línea punteada
borrando algunas secciones de esta línea
y espero que al menos para ustedes se
vea punteada así que estamos
convirtiendo esto en una línea punteada
esta es la frontera pero no lo estamos
incluyendo ok las coordenadas que
satisfacen esta desigualdad son toda
esta área sombreada con amarillo que
tenemos por encima de la línea bueno
espero les haya sido útil